To solve this problem, I started with a force diagram
and this green square here is going to represent our green car.
As always, we have the weight force pushing down mg
and we also have each of the four springs pushing up on a car.
We have four separate spring forces here, four forces pushing up on the car.
In order for this car body to be at rest not accelerating,
it must be the case that these four forces from the springs combine
must perfectly balance the weight force mg.
We can now say that four times the force of one spring must be equal to the weight force.
Using Hooke's law here and then doing a little bit of algebra
we find that the change in x the distance away from the equilibrium point
that these springs get pushed is equal to mg/4K for one of the springs.
And plugging in values for all these constants, I find that Δx is equal to 5 cm. Good work!